hey magnus you won the match against
aryanthari so
how was it i thought especially the
first game was very very tough
uh we're spending a lot of time and i
was not
getting anywhere and i was really
nervous
for both of us i think during time
pressure and then yeah fortunately
uh he uh made a couple of mistakes there
and
managed to win and then i sort of calmed
down um
today i um
sort of just trying to play play a game
um
since i feel that i haven't played so
much
classical chess in a long time and i'm
playing a world championship much so i
need
i need training so that's why i wanted
to play um
play a series game today and uh i'm
yeah i'm happy with the way it's
unfolded i was never
never in danger and eventually i ground
him down
so do you know your next opponent uh i
think it's uh
matlock for uh weitarshek and they're
playing a tiebreak so
oh yes and we were seeing you walking
around the tables and seeing other games
in the opening so is it helping you
while playing your game i don't think it
helps me but i
i enjoy it i usually
uh it's tournaments there aren't some so
many
so many games i'm trying also to get
some some ideas maybe
um but yeah uh obviously now
i think fabiano he lost he lost so
yeah it's uh that's a bit of a bit of a
shock
um otherwise i don't know
thank you very much and have a good rest
thank you